hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the topics that we're going to
find discussed in lactances on the anger
of God is virtues and vices now virtues
typically are understood as good
character traits qualities of a person
vices as their opposites bad or evil
character traits dispositions whatever
we want to call them and lactancius is
going to tell us that you know there
aren't any vices in God although there
is anger in God which means that there
is a possibility for anger to be
virtuous because God is completely
virtuous the question then is well what
about us human beings we can be indeed
on either side of Vice or virtue and
he's going to reference this and some
connected ideas throughout the treaties
I should point out that he also talks
about this in is much longer Institution
or institutes and that you can find to
some degree of Fuller treatment there
here we're particularly interested in
the relation between you know the parts
of the human being and so he begins by
telling us in chapter 19 where this is
being most addressed that the human
being is composed of body and soul and
this presents certain problems because
for lactances at least these are going
to be aligned with virtues and vices of
the person so he says because the human
being is made up of two parts body and
soul the virtues are contained in the
one namely in the soul and the vices in
the other the body and they mutually
oppose each other right they you could
even say they combat each other and they
do so sort of you know in vikum that is
mutually they're not inactive you could
say there's sort of a struggle going on
within the human being
and so you know there's a big question
which way are we going to go are we
going to go the way of the body or the
way of the soul and he says the good
Properties or the goods literally The
Bona of the uh Soul
consists in
there we go
restraining the lusts right uh libido is
lost in that case holding it back right
and they're going to be contrary to the
body they are going to be opposite to it
oppose it you could say right whereas
the goods in the body The Bona and these
are Goods of the body they're just not
the good as such consists in as he says
all types of Pleasures right Omnia
Genera all the different sorts of
pleasures and here he uses a different
term instead of just being opposed to
their hostile to their enemies
to the soul even though if you think it
through they're also seductive they're
trying to bring the soul in to the
purview of the body trying to turn the
the soul into maybe a mere appendage of
it so we've got some contrast some
opposition even some enmity there going
on and so you know he uh goes on and he
says
um if the virtue of the Soul resists
these desires and suppress them it'll be
truly like to God it'll be similar to
God and then he says from which it is
evident that the soul of the human being
which is capable of divine virtue is not
mortal there's an immortal part of
ourselves but there is this distinction
what is the distinction since virtue is
attended with bitterness
right literally the taste of bitterness
virtue is difficult virtue is not
something that is immediately pleasing
and and you know we should be very
realistic about this he thinks not you
know pretend that virtue is inherently
attractive to all human beings right off
the bat that's not the case
so because virtue is accompanied by or
involves some sort of bitterness
a lot of people don't really want to
cultivate it right they may even see it
as bad the attraction of pleasure is
sweet for the ancients
bitterness and sweetness as far as taste
we're on ends of a spectrum you couldn't
get further away from sweetness than
bitterness they didn't have you know the
sort of foretaste idea that we had as a
matter of fact in ancient times a lot of
people recognize seven eight nine
sometimes even more flavors to food but
they are usually arranged with
bitterness on one end and sweetness on
the other now of course virtue once you
practice it and you see the rewards is
sweet but most people
are attracted to pleasure because it
feels nice right so there's a choice to
be made virtue or pleasure and following
pleasure is going to result in Vice so
he says great numbers are overcome and
drawn aside to the pleasantness but
those who have given themselves up to
the body and Earthly things are pressed
to the Earth unable to attain to the
favor of the Divine Bounty they have
polluted themselves with the defilement
of vices so by pursuing the pleasures of
the body to the exclusion of the virtues
of the Soul well you wind up running
into all sorts of problems but on the
other hand if you as he says follow and
obey God and despise or look down upon
the desires of the body and prefer
choose deliberately choose virtue to
Pleasures you you preserve innocence and
righteousness and those people aren't
just like God God recognizes them as
being similar at least as much as a
human being can be to God so virtue you
know is going to be the way up it's the
way of the Soul uh vices are rooted in
the body they do infect the soul and
bring it down you could say and then
he's got a few other important
discussions that take place leading up
to this a little bit earlier on
there's this very interesting chapter 15
where he's dealing with the question
some may ask why did sins extend to man
or what perversion distorted the rule of
the Divine institution to worse things
so that the human being born to Justice
nevertheless performs unjust works now
Justice and Injustice virtue and vice
right those are understood as that and
his answer to this is very interesting
he Echoes something he said a little bit
earlier God put before or
set before human beings good things and
bad things and then said well you have
to actually decide between these he
didn't determine human Choice like he
said
God at the same time set before him
means he God loves the good he hates the
evil which is contrary to that but he
permitted the evil on this account that
the good also might shine forth and here
he goes into a discussion about
opposites and contraries and how you
need one in order to be able to
appreciate or see the other but then he
goes on and he brings up the body and
soul again right he says we are composed
of two substances soul and body one of
which is assigned to the heaven because
it's slight and not to be handled the
other to the Earth because it's capable
of being laid hold of the one is firm
and eternal the other frail and mortal
good clings to one and evil to the other
light life and Justice to the one
Darkness death and Injustice to the
other so once again we have the body and
soul opposition and so he says this is
why there arose among human beings the
corruption of their nature and this made
it necessary that a law should be
established a law by God right and we
could parse this out in different ways
what's important here the law actually
does two things with respect to Virtue
advice it prohibits vices don't do this
don't be this way don't do this sort of
thing and it actually commands you know
imperi is the the Latin the virtues it
tells human beings you need to behave in
this way you need to cultivate this sort
of character and mindset and temperament
so he says there are good and evil
things in the Affairs of human beings it
must be that God has moved to both sides
to favor when he sees just things are
done virtuous things are done to anger
when he perceives unjust things right
in the next chapter chapter 16 where
lactancias is talking about whether God
can feel anger he says that God doesn't
feel certain emotions although he does
feel other emotions why what's the
differentiating factor some emotions are
virtuous or capable of being virtuous
and others are vicious so you know he
says for example
um
here we go
there are some affections to which God
is Not liable what are they desire fear
avarice grief Envy why is he not subject
to these because they're vicious
affections they are the way that Vice
manifests itself but as to those which
belong to Virtue and he he talks about
three right here anger towards the
wicked not just anger per se or anger at
anybody whatsoever but anger towards the
bad the malos right uh what else love or
Caritas towards the good that is a
virtuous emotion as well and then pity
towards The Afflicted right so these are
good ways of being these fit in with
virtue those other emotions that we
mentioned
well you know not so good right
um some of them like Envy always going
to be bad
in chapter 18 uh leading up to the
discussion in chapter 19. he's going to
tell us some other things uh he he
mentions that there are people who are
ignorant of the ends of Good and Evil
things now this is a very important term
in ancient philosophy and you can say an
ancient culture more broadly within you
know the Mediterranean and near East the
intellectual culture talked about the
ends the Phoenix or the Telly right of
goods and evil understanding that what
we mean by this are things like like
happiness or misery right what does
ultimate happiness blessedness
consistent what does unhappiness or
misery consistent goods and bads so
there are some Goods like you know like
for example pleasure right pleasure can
be understood like you said as the good
of the body but it's not the good per se
there is a greater good that may require
you to forego or subordinate or limit
pleasure so being ignorant of the ends
of goods and evils means being ignorant
of the the right understanding of this
it's possible to have distorted mistaken
understandings of this and what is going
to happen if that's the case well he
tells us a few things one of these has
to do with the pleasures right he says
that
they enjoy sensual desire
uh you know libido again for the
purposes of corruption and Pleasures
voluptates we wind up directing our
desire to those Pleasures that we want
to enjoy so maybe we eat too much we're
glotness or we're lustful or you know
we're greedy we're trying to store too
many resources for ourselves and
depriving others but we can also go
wrong
if we're ignorant of these things with
respect to anger there is vicious anger
possible for human beings he says they
make use of anger and passion affect you
in this case
for what for inflicting of injury injury
to other people and he says while
they're angry with those they regard
with hatred and this leads into vicious
Behavior prime example of this they are
angry even with Those who commit no
offense even with their equals or even
with their superiors they daily rush to
monstrous Deeds hence tragedies often
arise
and if you actually look at Greek
tragedies you you see an awful lot of
like anger going in the wrong direction
at the wrong person leading to all sorts
of problems right
so it's possible for us to become
vicious by not understanding how we
ought to behave and he goes on and he
talks about you know self-restraint
um you know and uh times when we can you
know be involved in virtue and then he
says we have to avoid Vice being mingled
with Frailty once again we see this
theme coming up derived from the earth
we're unable to preserve pure and
uncontaminated that which we've received
from God unless we're imbued with the
precepts of Justice from the same God so
the Divine guidance as we've seen
earlier helps to lead us away from Vice
and towards virtue to prioritizing the
soul and its virtues and deprioritizing
you know lowering in the scale of
preference the pleasures that the body
would otherwise direct us towards which
get us into vices and all sorts of
trouble so for human beings we certainly
are capable of virtue or vice but we
have to choose to prioritize things in
the right way and this is what wisdom
practical wisdom in fact consists in and
we have guidance for doing so that
allows us to avoid vices particularly
vices concerned with how we manage our
anger